Lori Loughlin and her husband Massimo
are pleading not guilty to the charges
against them in the College Admission
scandal et has obtained the court
documents both signing on the dotted
line the pair's accused of paying
$500,000 and bribes to get their
daughters 19 year-old Olivia and 20
year-old Bella admitted to the
University of Southern California I just
want them to have that experience and
get that education and have a degree to
fall back on this news comes just days
after both Lori and Massimo rejected an
initial plea deal and were then charged
in a second superseding indictment on
conspiring to commit fraud and money
laundering a decision legal expert
Rachel Stockman thought they should
reconsider according to the prosecution
they have some pretty damning evidence
in the form of tapes recordings of Lori
so I think it's gonna be a very hard
case to fight in court if convicted the
fuller house star could receive up to 40
years in prison though a source tells ET
that it wasn't until recently that Lori
believed she would face time behind bars
at all Lori still believed in the end
she would just get a slap on the wrist
at this point she is getting complete
clarity and she's scared and in terrible
shape I think that there are several
risks if she does not take a plea deal
here and decides to take this to trial
for one all the evidence is going to
come out in the public against her and
that could be potentially very
embarrassing - you also have the
potential that the feds could add more
charges if they uncover more evidence
that is not favorable to Lori I think
the likelihood that Lori spends prison
time is very very high because of the
seriousness of the crime and the amount
of money that we're dealing with here et
has learned both of Lori's daughters are
hurt by all of this I think in some way
they're both destined to be in the
entertainment industry how do you
nurture that and support that you know I
just have to if I look I did everything
I can in my powers to say when they were
younger look these are the pitfalls
these are the pitfalls and the
are the pitfalls and then they both
decided like you know we're gonna do it
anyway so I have to support them I would
be a hypocrite if I didn't and you know
what you know we're here once that we
know of go for the go for the gold right
you got to do it and with you as a mom
it doesn't seem like you've had very
many pitfalls lots of successes oh thank
you very much I mean we've had our
moments but overall I'm happy and proud
of my girls and I think that they are
nice people and they are kind people and
I think that's the greatest compliment I
can give them
[Music]